pour cette deuxième distribution
solidaire plus de 200 paniers sont
préparés dans ce local à l'intérieur de
la nourriture et des produits d'hygiène
pour tenir un peu plus d'une semaine
une initiative de l'agora et l'épicerie
sociale et solidaire de l'ue vs q c'est
l'étudiant prend tout ce qui est proposé
il y à des légumes de producteurs locaux
il ya des pâtes du riz une grosseur du
pup et de tomates une bouteille de jus
de fruits de briques de lait du papier
toilette de des produits d'hygiène
féminine également de la compote des
pommes et pour le petit déjeuner soit
des céréales soit de la brioche ce jour
là les paniers sont répartis sur
plusieurs sites de distribution vélizy
versailles ou encore guyancourt ils sont
destinés en priorité aux étudiants en
situation de précarité financière et aux
étudiants santé mobilisés dans la crise
sanitaire
c'est une situation qu'on reconnaît tout
au long de l'année et qui déjà assez
difficile à vivre pour ces étudiants là
mais qui est vraiment très accentués et
difficile à vivre et des étudiants qui
nous disent qu'ils se nourrissent une
fois par jour pour éviter de gaspiller
et pour pouvoir tenir sur la durée mais
une fois par jour
c'est quand même une 8 sachant qu'en
général une fois par jour c'est par bon
repas c'est une fois par jour une
assiette de pâtes
l'association a reçu une enveloppe de
5000 euros pour confectionner ses
paniers d'une valeur de 18 euros
ça soulage un peu et ça facilite les
fins de mois surtout mes parents
pouvait jusqu'à maintenant assumer les
frais course et compagnie sauf que là
avec mon co vide chômage technique et
compagnie c'est pour les distributions
de ces paniers garnis se poursuivront
pendant tout le mois de mai pour
s'inscrire rendez vous sur la page
facebook de l'association agora